so yeah so even despite this I mean he
has struggled so be it whatever the
reason might be he's lost or struggled
to win against players who are 400 or
more points lower rate than Madness
Carlson but again time will tell
obviously oh come on Hikaru like like
he's reading off of like a script of
like trying to like make insinuations
you know it's it's just it's just like
it's just ridiculous like he knows what
he's saying is just like complete
complete like like I've lost a
struggle to 400 points like okay I lost
like one game like like are you kidding
me like like it's ridiculous like he has
no idea what he's saying and he even
knows that it's complete like
are you kidding me I've because I lost
one game you're trying to now insinuate
that I'm not a good chess player like
it's just ridiculous
like maybe I could respect him if he had
the the nerve to actually say what he
means but he hides High innuendo and and
these like random stupid statistics you
know